so in today's video we're going to talk
about relevance as a concept for
understanding how good search engines
are and that's because so in the last
two videos we've talked about how search
engines index different web pages and
then after that we looked at how search
engines rank different web pages the
links are both of those are in the
description below so in one of the
comments in the last video is someone
asked about relevance because this is a
pretty fundamental concept to search
engines deciding if a results in the
search engine is relevant or not
relevant is kind of a key stage and
there's lots of different ways you can
use that to evaluate how good your
search engine is so in order to discuss
relevance what we need is several things
we need a set of things we're going to
search for so for this we're using my
handy monopoly pieces and then we need a
set of documents which we've got here
which are results that this search
engine could return so then a third
thing is a list of which results are
relevant for the search that you're
looking for and for this I'm using nice
big red hotels for things that are
relevant and small green houses for
things that are not relevant so then
ultimately what a search engine wants to
do is to only return the relevant ones
so just to get all the hotels out that
would be nice if our search engine just
retrieves all of these and not get any
of the houses back that would be the
ideal situation for any search engine
and that would be true for whatever we
searched for now this is obviously not
necessarily very easy to do so what we
tend to have is two measures one is
precision and one is recall now recall
is the measure of how many of the
relevant ones we managed to get back so
who managed to get all of these hotels
back nicely then what we have is a
hundred percent recall but what's more
likely is that we managed to get some
portion of them back and so we have
maybe 70 percent recall now the second
thing is what is precision and this is
the number of returned results which are
actually relevant so say my search
engine brought back these results then
it's precision is what five out of nine
which is a random number results two
returns let's do that that's five out of
ten so it's got fifty percent precision
now in this case its recall was five out
of a possible I should have figured out
how many there are these
13 the RICO here is 5 out of 13 and the
precision was 5 out of 10 so in order to
compare all of these different
algorithms we produced to make our
search engine better what we want is a
nice score to be able to say what we've
done so a score for precision is the
number of results that you return which
were irrelevant divided by the overall
number of results you return so this
would be 5 divided by 10 if you want a
score for recall then what you're doing
is taking the number of relevant results
you returned divided by the total number
you could have returned which is 5
divided by 13 not an easy number to
immediately come up with so if we take a
single measure which combines both
precision and recall we have what's
called the F measure and the simplest
form of the F measure is 2 divided by 1
by 2 the right the precision plus 1
divided by the recall it's yeah there's
more complicated versions which add some
weights and some likelihood of errors
and things like that but the simplest
version is that simple comparison all
that's doing is saying if I get a good
precision score and a good a recall
score then I'll get a good F measure
school people have produced sets of
results where there are maybe a million
results that could be returned and
they've pre decided on six different
searches that we will go for and they
have pre decided that for this search of
certain set documents are ones which are
relevant and for this research there's
different set of documents are relevant
so what we have is a known set of
documents and known set of searches and
a known set of right answers and search
engines have used this principle which
is called the Cranfield paradigm for
about 60 years to improve search engines
so reach every time one research
university or people from Google or Bing
say we've got an improvement to our
algorithm which we think is going to be
better they can take a known to hit of
data assets a known set of results or
own set of right answers and they can
say based on these and our algorithm we
get a score which are slightly better
and that score might be higher precision
or it might be higher recall there's
actually a number of different measures
but it means essentially everybody's
been able to compete for 60 years on who
can get the best algorithm so if we
wanted to build a system which always
achieved 100 cent recall that would be
very easy I've just returned everything
and in there I definitely have a
don't recall because I definitely got
everything but that's not necessarily
good but if you wanted a house every
call that would work another way to get
the answer one is if you want to make
sure you always get one hundred percent
precision would be to just take the very
best answer and say I'm pretty confident
that's going to be a good one I've got
100 precision I only returned one and it
was relevant but I missed out on lots of
things so our aim tends to be I want to
get as many as the US as possible
someone get high recall but I want to do
that without losing precision it's 2
divided by 1 divided by precision plus 1
divided by recall and so then what we
can get is my set of results I returned
four this has more specific f score so
now I'm gonna bring in my separate sets
so my first algorithm is bringing back
my nice retro wooden houses and hotels
and my brand new algorithm which is
going to make me a million pounds is
gonna use these shiny plastic hotels and
houses so we have two separate
algorithms we did one search which was
my shiny car but both algorithms
returned six relevant results and four
not relevant results and so it doesn't
really matter what our score is because
the F score is the same for both of them
we didn't manage to differentiate
between which algorithm was better so we
start to ask questions how do we decide
which algorithm is better and the first
way of doing this is to say well a
better algorithm if it's going to return
six good ones out of ten it's gonna put
those six good ones higher than the
other one
so if one algorithm is producing
relevant relevant and not relevant
relevant relevant not relevant and so on
down to the bottom then a better
algorithm would have relevant relevant
relevant relevant for animals and
they're not relevant afterwards so we
want is a measure that will say this
result set this better than that result
set and so for this what we use is an
average precision score and to calculate
average position the easy form of what
we do is for every result we bring in we
give it a score of one if it's relevant
and we divide it by the fact we brought
in the new number so here we have we
brought in one year results and we
divide it by one because that's how many
doctors we brought in here we have
another relevant result so we've got two
relevant ones now and we divide it by
the fact that we've got two so far next
time though we didn't get a relevant
result
so we're still only at two relevant ones
but we've brought three in and then here
were three four four four five four four
six oh no five four seven and so on down
to the bottom
but over here we had one four one two
four two three four three four four four
and so on to the point here where we
start getting only six four seven and so
then what you do is you add up all these
scores to get an average precision
school so here we have this is one this
is one but now we get zero point six and
then we get zero point seven four five
for this one and zero point eight for
this one right over here we had one one
one one one one and so the sum of these
is going to be lower than the sum of
these and so this is a better response
even though we got the same number that
were relevant back we put them all at
the top and got a higher score for doing
it so essentially he's saying the case
we actually got on the left side divided
by the ideal case and so the ideal case
is we get them all at the top and here
we actually did well we'd actually like
his mean average and we like to know
that we get this type of better answer
every single time so for my shiny car I
got a better result from this algorithm
because the good ones were at the top
but for my nice top hat suddenly we
brought all bad results at the top so
this doesn't work for a top hat very
well and even on this one it got two bad
ones quite high up and so what you want
is a score which is what you got for
everything image to the point where you
bring my awesome horse into the search
engine with evil Santa with weapons on
top of things to my son then from this
particular score both of them did
excellently because my search engine is
optimized on pony horse dog horse to
really bring back horse paste products
but then what your mean average
precision score gives you is the average
score you got for every single query
that you did when you know the answer so
in general the average score for
searches was higher for this one
compared to the first algorithm we had
but if you had only one example where
you got good results for my awesome
horse but for everything else you were
getting bad results before it so your
mean average precision as you say over
all my queries which one which algorithm
is performing best
it's been a while since we've checked
that website I wonder if it's changed
since we last went there maybe it has
different words in it now we'll go and
check it and then when it gets there it
says and we use that to sort of try and
go how far away things are and that's
what they're doing here